[Musique]
Maxime qui joue roi G8 et là peut-être
cavalier D3 alors dis donc
à deux et avantage blanc mais quelle
partie qui n'est en train de faire un
dépôt
c'est impressionnant il va réussir à
faire B4 et à mettre pression mesdames
et messieurs ce que Diane n'est pas bien
chier vient de faire sur cette séquence
de coût et absolument incroyable c'est
du jamais vu sur cavalier à 6 il y a roi
D8 B8 dames il prend G4 H4 G3 et le
cavalier a pas le temps de revenir
apparemment donc ces cavaliers à 6 3D 8
3D 5 le coup peut-être
H4 G4 H4 il y a pas de G3 parce qu'il y
a dam oh il va y avoir roi E4 B8 dam le
cavalier va revenir et c'est gagnant
pour nepo quel début de match de Yann
F4 et on va prendre des quatre non il y
aurait du dames c'est catac
il est peut-être en train de la tenir
allez
elle fait tellement bien
il en a eu pas mal qu'on ne sait pas qui
évaluer à 6 le coup tu sais plutôt bah
qui ah c'est terrible oh tu es pas bien
en fait
je sais plus si c'était cavaliers à 6 ou
fuj4 mais je pense il en a eu
quelques-unes contre top non ok
j'aimerais jouer de bouger la tour et
jouer B3 mais ça va pas être possible si
il fait un coup comme à 4 et il va
Maxime va jouer B4 et il va poser
problème
toi
pas réfléchit longtemps oh là là il a
disparu vite ce pion à deux
je crois que ça l'a fait tilter là la
dernière la finale là il laisse du Tour
des cinq non des 5 tours à 5 bah ouais
bizarre ouais mais je te dis que nepo et
je trouve qu'il défend extrêmement bien
il est il faut faire attention parce que
tourgé si il y a tout reprend H5 je
crois j'ai 8 tours J6 puis on prend et
tu auras 5 le pion le pion part pas tout
seul et là il veut quoi tour à 4
peut-être ouais bien joué
5 tours J6 pour prendre pion prend pour
prendre et il y aura permet de foodé 4
il aura tout reprend des quatre salaires
de passer ça bien joué là bien joué
qu'est-ce que ça défend bien mais pour
en gagner une c'était pas facile bon pas
une partie où il va se passer grand
chose quand même
attends qui est H2 pour que G4 il peut
encore y avoir de la vie qui va faire
tout aussi
sept pour pas laisser de cavalier E5
ouais puis ça devient plus agréable pour
les blancs quand même je sais pas j'ai
l'impression en blitz en tout cas que le
cavalier tu as peut-être un peu plus de
potentiel là tu as peut-être du Tour 6 à
Tours c'est 7 il veut dame 6
ça donne envie mais après tu te mets
dans le fou aussi quand même
première vue je pensais que ton C7
c'était tu sais peut-être dame 8
recettes ce truc comme ça mais non là ça
passe pas parce qu'en plus après le tour
C7 il peut même y avoir des dames G4
peut-être pas sûr il y aurait d'un point
F7 ouh là pardon joli rappelle
l'intervention
[Rires]
de temps en temps que j'envoie quand
même une mais il faut peut-être faire
dame B2 en fait et plutôt fou A1 je
dirais pour cavalier aussi parce que si
tu fais dame B2 qui a valu aussi
alors l'ordi donne gagnant après
cavalier G5 sur wife 6 ah bah voilà tu
vois il a eu le même donc la défense a
été pas facile bah là c'est Dame C8 et
cavaliers G5 on va aller chercher F7 là
ça va gagner ouais
quand on en parlait un époque qui jouait
très bien mais qui peut craquer là
Maxime il peut peut-être lui en prendre
une autre derrière et faire la diff bon
là c'est ma tante monsieur allez elle
fait du bien la maxime qui souffle hein
Maxime qui a trouvé le très joli comme
ça il a très très bien défendu allez
c'est bien là c'est exactement ce qu'il
fallait
j'ai deux peut-être
cinq ok attention un petit peu quand
même ah du coup ça lui permet surtout
rien d'avoir
B8 échec intermédiaire tour à 7
attention on tour à 7 tu auras 8 il fait
tomber un simplement oh bien joué ça
pour dame j'ai 5 mais il va faire H4 non
H4 la F4 ouais mais H4 d'un S4
un parti
c'est pas trop vite ça va trop vite pour
nous surtout
ok ça va être intéressant
ah mais il peut juste GF en fait
le dame G5 était il fallait
il fallait le jouer le DAB G5 très bien
joué un de la part de Maxime nous on
était parti dans un délire après là ça
va signer
il trouve que l'issc7 tours F6 dans le 7
attention ça peut être même bien pour
les Noirs il y a pas d'âme c'est Adam
c'est trois il y a peut-être
on en parlait un de cette partie qui
pouvait c'est un peu dommage parce qu'il
avait de nouveau les blancs
c'est n'importe quoi c'est pas possible
en fait
avec les noirs
c'est Maxime qui au blanc ils arrivent
pas à voir les bonnes couleurs chiase
commode là
c'est ce que tu vas devoir faire tu as
pas tout reprendre
qui tourne pas le fou c'est ça
c'était pas possible allez une belle
position là Maxime
le roi le roi blanc est faible après
alors après attention parce que les
finales elles peuvent être compliquées
le roi blanc est faible mais si ça part
en finale le roi blanc il est plus
proche du centre quand même il y a
peut-être C6 encore mais ouais non mais
il se rapproche il se rapproche du gars
mais là ça ressemble à gagner on y a pas
G5 on reprend à 7 G4
ça doit gagner aussi
qui parle bah oui oui puisque tu as 1000
€ en cage est assez qui part et la
finale de pion elle devait être nulle
quand même mais elle devait pas être
facile de toute façon tu oui
tu peux pas manger ces deux ce que la
finale de pion est perdante donc
qui se fait sortir allez c'est peut-être
le moment là de faire le break avec les
Blancs Maxime
c'est pas possible
c'était plus pour échanger on le sait
avoir une belle une belle finale mais là
ça ressemble de plus en plus à gagnant
tout échanger avoir la finale
avantageuse mais là ça ressemble à gain
direct non ouais parce que j'ai vu tu as
raison juste à trois ah peut-être juste
à trois par exemple H6 mais bon à B HG
qui a les process tu gagnes un pion en
Punto déjà avec les Blancs tes proches
de gains mais il faut prendre un fils
peut-être tu aurais fuite
en G7 tu peux prendre en D2 tu peux tout
enfin non c'est trop faut prendre des
deux il va trouver Maxime ça va faire
deux points d'écart
[Musique]
il y a tout qui paraissait bien pour les
blancs mais faut même si c'était assez
facile bizarre devait pas s'attendre bah
tu vois il a pas pu en prendre
c'est loin d'être fait là c'est hyper
compliqué il veut tout repenser 7 il
faut prendre B2 et il y a pas ton
français 5 à cause de fous des quatre
mais ils sont insupportables moi ils me
font peur ces gens hé regarde il veut
prendre CB et faire A4 non même pas je
pensais que vous les CB CB A4 ton
français 7 vous prend B2 et jouer elle
était intéressante
il avait peut-être une chance d'ailleurs
avec ça
il est pas du tout après l'ordi de n'est
pas du tout ce que j'ai dit ce que je
viens de dire là c'était ouais mais ça a
l'air intéressant
ok mais
ça c'est ce que c'est facile
ça c'est nul
c'est trop cette partie et là la
technique c'est d'aller dans le coin à 8
Maxime d'ailleurs qui qui essaye même
pas ça joue pas mal là
ok fou des 7
et ça date et ça doit défendre sa bâti
maintenant
c'est les Vals c'est 0 0
qui part peut-être la meilleure chance
pour tenter de jouer le gain c'est Dame
prend le 4 mais il y aura pris ses 6
c'est dommage 5D et attention Yann qui
relève passer en demi point là Maxime
qui avait raté le coche dans la partie
précédente penser que n'est pas
égaliserait cette fois-ci c'est Maxime
qui défend au top le tour des trois bien
joué encore il fait roi de 7 assez
précises quand même de très très haut
niveau
pour 3 il va faire [ __ ] 2 mais bon là
ça devrait aller roi français 7 ça
devrait aller cette fois-ci
la défense de Maxime que c'est des chocs
mais que en attaque jamais en défense ok
tu penses qu'ils ont un peu regardé
entre les parties probablement
en fait tu sais plus avant tu savais
Vaki qui est pas bien il a pu les infos
je sais pas
en fait boss pour Yann mais c'est
Patrick Bruel oui en fait on a toujours
su il bosse pour le Championnat du Monde
en fait Patrick de retour il s'est
toujours tout ah mais c'est du coup je
comprends maintenant pourquoi tu dis que
c'est chouette berlinois sont bizarres
baquis
encore
[Rires]
à cette tempo c'est beau
mais c'est hyper dangereux là parce que
surprend on reprend et cavalier cet
échec qui a pu en prendre dame prend
dame D8 Dame des trois jolies de Maxime
il a vu évidemment ça il y a toujours à
huit ici je suis 10 secondes pour Yann
allez ça va le faire pour Maxime bah ça
a pas été vu par Yann
oui même moi j'avais même moi j'avais
oui c'est bon en fait ça joue pas si
bien bah qui désolé on vous a trompé sur
les marchandises
on fait des erreurs inhabituelles quand
même
ah bah ça c'était quand même pas très
dur pour que j'ai c'est que c'était pas
très dur j'aurais fait dame c'est un G6
en cours réflexe mais l'ordi donner ce
que tu as dit ouais
c'était juste pour prendre le pion
oui c'est vrai que c'est con mais c'est
efficace ouais
et là ça va être dû acheter pour ouvrir
le roi
bon ça ça gagne tranquille pour les
noirs
pas très dur ça non à gagner
je pense pas mais bon on sait jamais tu
as toujours des petites forteresses qui
peuvent se créer regarde la roi F6 ça
devient seul coup déjà non mais c'est
sûr qu'il faut la jouer mais c'était
juste une question
ouais il y a des fourchettes aussi on
peut se prendre des mais là c'est tout
F3 et le roi à quoi que le roi 4
cavalier
il va devoir jouer F5 F5
qui va gagner le match maximum il y a
trop de louper comme ça de ah bah ouais
mais bon
j'ai deux torset
bien épaule
moi je suis très heureux là j'ai les
coups là quand c'est des trucs à la con
comme ça je suis très heureux ça ou non
on leur dit de ne tomber un
plus ou moins seul coup de défense
ça va être joué mais à contrecœur
s
ça explose ça explose on a toujours su
depuis le début on a commencé à savoir
les trois premières parties j'étais pas
serein quand même ouais parce qu'il
jouait des coups vraiment trop fort et
là
il jouait fort et petit à petit Maxime
qui a pris sa mesure et là là le choc
dans la précédente 2 minutes 36 et avoir
cette poubelle c'est dur quoi
c'est peut-être le seul que je mâle oui
oui mais bon il va être gênant
oui c'est juste que tu envoies des punch
en fait à tout bout de champ maintenant
bah non mais bon c'est vrai quoi le mec
il est bosse j'ai fait deux sur deux bon
ce qui fait peur
oui c'est vrai j'avais oublié oui en
fait l'autre non plus ne fait pas peur
en fait sur le prochain match en fait
ça s'appelle de Punto ça joli tour
Eiffel
trop imparable derrière
bon mais là il y a pas assez la pause
normalement chez SCOM qui oublie les
pots non ah bah oui une petite pause bah
qui
elle fait du bien celle-là là il reste
24 minutes de jeu seulement derrière on
va pouvoir resoufler rapidement
et c'est du 1-0 en plus maintenant non
c'est encore 3 + 5 là c'est la pause des
trois plus simples qui attendent
c'est beau
problème avec son roi Maxime pas facile
à jouer mais il a réussi à jouer vite
quand même à bien défendre quand il a
peu de temps maximum on le sent très
affûté
c'est bien joué il se replace attention
quand même un les cases noires
ça s'approche du roi la Baki la dame qui
est en train d'arriver en F6 la maxime
qui a plus de temps plus de 20 secondes
tu reprends des 5D en plus c'est [ __ ]
non ça marche pas j'ai peur que ça qu'on
s'incline ici
Yann qui réussit à s'accrocher à nos
basques
ça sort les ouvertures interdites côté
Yann
heureusement peut-être que l'arbitrage
de peut-être c'est les arbitres comme un
qui sont intervenus on l'a vu réfléchir
un petit peu il a pas fait la ruse et
maintenant en fait que le fouet décalé
il y a plus d'harmonie donc il va faire
que j'ai 6 mais bon ça reste un peu
mieux pour les Noirs quand même
pas terrible
attention bien joué peut-être fouter 3
il va faire tout
attention Maxime attention ouais elle
est chaude en réalité il est revenu il
est revenu mais bon
3 enfin il y a pas il y a mais ça c'est
nul juste non
ouais cavalier
ok les deux sont sortent bien
les deux s'en sortent bien
et puis ça finit on s'est
pas si vous arrivez à suivre mais même
nous on a du mal à suivre
des six ou un truc comme ça qui gagnait
pour les Noirs ça s'est joué juste
alors il se trouve que F4 c'était dans
les seuls coups qui perdaient
roi des trois rois 3 et tu reprends F4
tours des 4 droits
autour des 4 tout de suite d'ailleurs
tu as raison en fait ça va Yann qui fait
trop de trop négligent
le plus simple d'après ordi c'est roi G7
tours
voilà
ok mais fallait trouver quand même
c'est quand même reconcentré au bon
moment
à sa technique de gain c'est pas c'est
pas l'assurance touriste
ça va faire plus de mais ouais ça aurait
pu être quasi égalité quand on y pense
dangereux attention à la maxime
de pas se faire ouvrir
ouais ça clique ça clique de partout bah
qui
voilà c'est compliqué la position est
complexe
mais je le sens bien ce Punto en ces
deux mois
les 20 secondes d'écart aussi
mais bon
il va quand même Adam ouais ça va faire
Punto Yann qui suit
c'est une tourelle non ça il va encore
être tenté qu'il y ait des quatre ou
quelque chose comme ça non mais oui il
peut même pas parce qu'il y avait le fou
en l'air
faut abandonner là Monsieur après s'il
veut jouer et faire couler le temps on
est peut-être pas contre en réalité
allez il faut il faut continuer et la
maxime qui joue mieux en belette ses
ouvertures là aussi ouais on sent la qui
fait les cars Maxime ça y est
il y a une qui recommence un peu à
craquer Maxime ouais
c'est ça explose ça baille il faut aller
dormir monsieur et Maxime qui lui a
l'air très affûté faut dire aussi qu'il
y a le championnat du monde de Bleach
fin décembre Maxime qui doit avoir à
coeur de défendre son titre voire même
d'aller chercher celui en rapide
si même là il laisse il laisse les dames
F3 il laisse énormément de chance les
cases blanches cette fois je crois
ça va encore faire Punto
ça va encore faire Punto backi et tout
réplique
c'est terminato ça va faire plus 5 tu
avais raison de dire que ce match
pouvait être long maintenant le 23
dernières minutes
ouais
c'est bien joué en réalité ouais
c'est probablement sale chance oui en
réalité c'est même très bien joué de la
part de Yann mais bon c'est trop ce
qu'il a fait attention à qui il va
menacer
5D
attention
et D8
attention on a peut-être chanté un peu
vite Baki enfin surtout moi
c'est 4 tours C3
c'est trop pour Yann
tout simplement
et ça c'est terminé
Tanger
Maxime ça y est cette fois-ci c'est fini
c'est mathématiquement fini backy il ne
peut plus rien arriver à Maxime
qui se qualifie
[Musique]